they swept through cities and kingdoms
riding their dead horses hunting with
their packs of pale spiders big as
hounds hey everybody it's Charlie there
was a big game of Thrones panel recently
that HBO held where they talked about
Season eight in the prequel show there
was a whole bunch of news so we got to
break it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's also a new round of
that 4k season one blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so this past week was Comic Con
but right now the TCAs are happening so
naturally HBO is talking about all the
television series that are coming up for
the next season
that of course concludes Game of Thrones
season 8 naturally all the press that
we're there we're asking about the
prequel series because they haven't
started shooting that yet so KC Boy is
sort of like mr. HBO when it comes to
official press announcements just sort
of lay down the law on what's going on
and what the status of everything is he
officially confirmed that season 8 will
be airing during the first half of next
year 2019 which we've all believed for a
long time
last year Maisie Williams Emilia Clarke
sir Davos all separately did interviews
explain the production schedule and
explain how they personally believe we'd
be seeing it earlier rather than later
next year like we'd all assume so set
your clocks for late April early May you
know at the latest early June what'll
probably happen is they're not gonna
unfreeze a block of ice to tell us
what's going on they'll just drop a
teaser in the date will be attached to
the end of the teaser maybe later this
year early next year but the other half
of the panel was dedicated to all things
prequel series so we know about the long
night prequel series he talked about
that but he also explained what's
happening with those other four prequels
that they were developing so remember
originally there were five we learned
about the long night then George RR
Martin's said that one of the other four
died leaving three one of those three
was rumored to be the rise of the
Valyrian freehold the title was reported
as Empire of ash but as of this morning
me posting this video HBO said that the
other four all of the other four aren't
happening so they're either dead or they
were crap and HBO doesn't want to make
them they're sitting on a shelf maybe
some of them will be revisited in future
years but as of right now the only
prequel series we're getting in 2020
will be the long night series remember
HBO
Game of Thrones they have a new lead ik
to crank out even more programming week
to week year to years than they have in
the past meaning they need all the new
premium content that they can get and
they just love Game of Thrones it's the
most popular thing that they have so
they would jump at the chance to have
two concurrent Game of Thrones series so
don't be surprised if in a couple years
you hear about another prequel series
starting but it sounds like for the next
couple of years is just gonna be the
long night maybe we'll find out what
some of those are the prequel ideas were
usually when they shutter something like
that they don't tell you what it was in
case they ever want to come back to it I
think everybody's pretty pumped up about
the long night is far enough removed
from events in present day that they're
not gonna step on the toes of anything
that the main show is done or the George
are Martin is getting ready to do with
winds of winter and dream of spring he
did say that he personally helped
produce the long night series as it's
getting ready to get started although
he's trying to avoid taking credit just
because anything with Game of Thrones in
the title is automatically attributed to
him regardless of how much or how little
he worked on it so yes he is involved
with the prequel series it's not like
the later seasons of the main show where
he sort of stepped away he's a little
more actively involved with what's going
on with a long night I think that's
mostly to help craft characters avoid
continuity errors in story elements that
wouldn't naturally work in A Song of Ice
and Fire things that you wouldn't expect
to find in a Game of Thrones series but
HBO said that they have not cast the
series yet and as of right now they're
officially looking for directors to
start shooting next year there was a
rumor started by the Belfast Telegraph
newspaper a little while ago they might
start production as soon as October in
Belfast the part about them filming in
Belfast is true but HBO said that they
wouldn't be ready to start till next
year
don't panic remember in earlier seasons
they wouldn't start production until
late summer so as long as the prequel
series can start shooting by late summer
2019 they can get season one out by
spring 2020 so you have season eight
spring 2019 then a year later you get
season one of the long night and
henceforth each year after that ten
episodes remember normal HBO show ten
episodes per season that's what we're
going back to after all this weirdness
the last couple of years with Game of
Thrones so if you're an actor that
really wants a job on this prequel
series you still have plenty of time to
get your tape to HBO because they
haven't
casting yet as for who the main
characters would be they're probably
gonna go with a lot of the mythical
figures from the Age of Heroes like bran
the Builder during God's grief land the
clever
who started House Lannister the grey
King the first king of the Iron Islands
you get the idea the mythical big
figures that you've heard about but who
have been distorted through the
retelling of legends so more on that the
plot they didn't say a whole lot about
the actual plot besides the official
synopsis they released a little while
ago I've already done a video about that
but they said that they would not be
retreading a lot of the stuff that the
main series has done so there's just a
couple points of crossover like the
creation of the night king the last long
night that we experienced they
officially confirmed that the prequel
series would be set eight thousand years
in the past because there's a weird
thing about the way the show treats
history in the way the books treat
history it's like tens of thousands of
years in the books but during season six
when brain was getting all those lessons
from the three-eyed Raven he made it
seem closer to a thousand years so
there's some inconsistency with the way
they treat the timeline but it seems
like based on what they've said the
prequel series will adhere more to the
timeline that you see in the books but
they did not say what would be happening
in present-day when the show picks up
whether it would start after the
creation of the night king here because
it's the long night and that happened
after the night king was created or if
it would pick up with the events of the
first war that the children in the
forest had with the first men or if they
would treat that like they're Robert's
rebellion we're like you just got
through a really big war then you have
this big watershed event that begins the
long night and just the entire series is
spent as things descend into permanent
or semi-permanent winter because
obviously they eventually defeated the
night king and because we've heard a lot
of stories from that period martin did
directly address how they'd be handling
that from a story perspective so he said
only one thing is sure
from the horrifying secrets of Westeros
is history - the true origin of the
White Walkers the mysteries of the east
remember we'll be dealing with stuff
that's happening the east like the rise
of the Valyrian freehold to the Starks
of a legend it's not the story we think
we know so it sounds like the stance
that they're taking with writing this
series is that the tales that we hear
from old nan have been distorted over
time through the oral histories that get
passed down generation to generation
so the actual
of how they teamed up to defeat the Nike
Ozora hi the Nissa Nissa of it off all
went down different than what we've
actually read just because the maesters
weren't around till much much later in
history during samwell's storyline at
the Citadel with maester ebro's even
they questioned the accuracy of history
from that period the tales of the long
night can't be pill fabrication too many
similarities from unconnected sources
the end of the Targaryen dynasty how
will we survive when Aegon Targaryen
turned his eye westward and flew his
dragons to Blackwater Russia the end is
near how will we survive and thousands
of years before that during the long
night we can forgive them for thinking
it truly was the end but it wasn't so I
think that also kind of confirms why
they probably dropped the Valyrian
prequel that they were working on
because they can just do that on this
series because there are a lot of
overlapping events between the rise of
the freehold and the first long night so
if you have any special requests for
Game of Thrones videos leave them in
comments below and let me know like what
do you want them to do on this main show
based on what we already know about that
period in history it would be really
exciting if the end this series with the
creation of the wall like the way they
destroy the wall at the end of the main
show maybe they create it at the end of
the prequel series but as we get more
info about it I'll do new videos
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Josh friend please email me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for that
Maisie Williams video and click here for
all my comic-con trailer videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight